[Music]
so I can't start finding sentences or so
any more according to Carmichael you
know what Carmichael and I were invited
to New York be at launch party for
Madden 2018 I'm assuming into 2017
yeah sounds about right so we're gonna
go to the launch party for Madden 2018
play some football visit New York meet
shonduras again for the hundredth time
maybe maybe maybe we can convince Shawn
to interest introduce us to Casey nice
that
[Music]
basically we're working on this feature
film
we got a script that's chugging along at
this point we're trying to project out
and figure out okay if this script is
done in five weeks maybe eight weeks
what do we do after that what stuff do
we need to start getting together now so
that in eight weeks time we can send out
information to other producers and other
parties to start getting money and
people and other things attached to the
project or is in the TV world webseries
world you pitch a concept someone buys
it and then you develop it in the movie
world you do all the developmental work
for free and then someone comes along
and it's like I like that I'll pay for
that
that's just the way that it is that's
what we're working on figuring out here
two locations got it no jump at it's at
its core there's gonna be a scary movie
yeah and I think that's the biggest
thing that we should remember going
through this because let's be honest the
feature film world is pretty messy right
now it's like a crumbling sand castle
and the only movies the only movies that
are low-budget and popular are scary
movies and especially with our track
record of having never produced a
theatrical feature before it would be
unlikely that somebody would come along
and one of both financing and a
distribution at the upfront yeah most
likely we do get financing and then
we'll have to figure out distribution
after it's made it's probably better to
think about this in bite sizes first we
we bite-sized the development then we
bite-sized production and creation of
the piece and the post-production and
all the things that go into producing it
and then we bite size distribution every
cool with the goal going theatrical for
this yeah I think that's a great goal
a car got hit and run here a side swiped
in the middle of street maybe throughout
the car in neutral I can push you over
there let's get you out of the road just
throw it in neutral we'll roll it he
doesn't want us to move the car I like
coming I like here we'll just push it
out of the way and he's like no no
life's an adventure when this stuff
happens where are we going
Harken sorry
way further south of protects the making
yeah we went the wrong way here IV not
gonna take a selfie with a broken down
bus
all right let's get back
in the other line because I can be
closed and I can take to line play in a
meadow yeah it's gonna be hard Sam
what's your thought on the traditional
film crew versus doing something a
little more custom corridor style that's
a good question how do we want to do
directing on this piece I need to join
the camera Union let's start doing
everything new the mowing sites project
do what you know what I know is I direct
and I shoot at the same time obviously
you both are gonna want director credit
so who's directing the actors and in
what scene and on and if you're gonna
break that up if you're gonna decide
that that's one person's job storyboards
are a good idea we should do those
especially for a rare very important
scene it has to be comprehensive yeah
but the plan is going to be sure for
example let's say there was a scene
tomorrow that was a really cool scene
and I was like damn it's gonna be 16 and
somehow you're doing it we could not we
cannot go into that day without a
comprehensive plan of what the shots are
going to be how it's gonna feel and all
that stuff to a point where both you and
I are almost on the same page where it
almost doesn't even matter who's on set
anymore because everyone is so like on
the same page exactly how things are
going down and we're all like let's do
this so what that requires in practice
is you need a lot more time during
photography like in it for every one day
that you think you need photography you
should plan to yeah having two directors
doubles the amount yeah shoot stuff
because it will require that time you'd
be like we only got in two minutes
yesterday because problems means hunting
with a crew of 40 you don't have time
and if film set is all about well-being
hitting that ground we need this this
whole this whole project is tailored to
you guys's strengths so let's not tailor
a crew against your strengths the pub G
shoot was part of us too it's is I've
really been thinking about how we got
into u2 and or Dennis stuff interesting
like we don't need a shoot by
traditional film sets because we can do
things at traditional film sets can well
certainly most our work is not of the
caliber of a film we still hold them a
lot of people and they want watch her
stuff ahead a certain spark you know
tour we have a certain spark to our work
and that's where after now having worked
with traditional film crews and having
done our own thing I'm really starting
to realize that if we try to just when
we get up to the level of shooting a
movie if we try to just simply stop
doing what we're doing and doing it the
additional way I'm gonna get to a movie
then we're not going to make anything
good yeah
we revealed all right got talk really
loud because music here is bumpin here
we are at the launch party for meta and
that's 18 2 K P 2018 1 even tried to get
IV score touchdown - I'm trying to hang
out shonduras the max 3 we're going to
try to get Carmichael JC nice vets
signature Casey 9 sets on the top of
this game he's one of the most respected
bloggers out there drama clubs up dome I
mean heck I look up to them but here we
are we're gonna play football first
[Music]
this is really cool the Patriots lost a
Super Bowl because of you I
hey go they go
[Applause]
[Music]
here's what's going down we are putting
together the ultimate football team
tonight commander MacKinnon shonduras
eco ultimate football team just like
Samson victory dances and touchdown man
with the Vikings courtesy after my own
heart
not nervous dog born for this oh cool
takes me back is my high school days
they called me helmet hang for they used
to call me shoulder pads on their
shoulder holders show endurance today
I've got to go up and play a Madden 18
tournament here he's gonna be the
quarterbacks he won the rock paper
scissors contest I'm really guided it's
a tango about arterback but you know
what do you ready backs important I'm
gonna be the one who scores the
touchdown dance man
Raja
no idea there was gonna be like a legit
crowd watching us team touchdown
[Music]
you know we have to we have to preserve
and hold on to what our strengths are
then just step up our game even more to
the point where we're executing on the
higher level but still the way we do it
but yeah we need to think a little bit
about not to forth answer today but we
need to think of it a little bit about
how I want to direct this because it
needs to be how we direct other things
it can't be a completely new system we
don't do storyboards I think we can do
some what we do everything when I can do
what they did for the matrix they made a
comic book the entire movie can't just
be in the head of one person it needs to
be in the head of as many people as
possible as clear as possible and so
once again storyboards will be a thing
that we'll need to do naturally for this
piece should we put his pants on today
or can we just shoot the top half very
important stuff that will save people
hours and hours of time and storyboard
is the only way that people will
understand yes like weight sense where
the sequences that Dakkar them but like
I mentioned we had to stay true to how
we work one thing that we have been
doing since Assassin's Creed 3 planning
additional time not just in the two days
where we're actually planning on
shooting something that was originally
scoped this one but a third day on
certain days to actually go and video
board with the actors who doesn't like
actually sit there and walk through and
talk about the scene and talk of and we
do that with the art director and do
that with the director of photography
and like be able to especially going
into big scene changes you know one one
thing one thing that we've never done so
far but we should definitely do it's
just that though which is when you are
dealing with big location changes or
doing with anything that is more than
simply two people talking at each other
like literally just going alright I we
are in production but literally Monday
is now a planning day yeah where
everyone just literally we go to
location we go through the scenes that
are will be shot that week bring
everyone back onto the same page again
so no one's being caught off guard this
is in the YouTube environment having no
costs when you're going into shooting a
video
and having the attitude of like well we
tried this today so it didn't work so
we're gonna come back the next day and
we're gonna try this has really really
helped videos yeah and I would implement
that here I think building building this
shoot for time and giving time as our
greatest resource like producer needs to
be able to do that and build that into
the costs basically let's say there's
three locations that basically adds nine
days unto the filming schedule we are in
production each location has its own
planning day it has its own video board
day for anything that needs to be
comprehensive and it's also got its
pickup day but pretty late yeah find out
it's 7:00 you can make the Beast
[Music]
when Samuel oh really
oh my god there's like they only
introduce your side they didn't
introduce our plate really really
awkward
hey I did get that Juke and all in all
I'm saying is on our gaming channel note
we're known for some sick jokes like we
all know that like if you had more time
to practice
we all know we all know have one last
thing to do you still have not yet
gotten Carmichael a case in the East at
nice that autograph sorry KC I
mispronounced their last name I don't
even know if you watch just blocks KC
I'm talking directly to KC I know
there's thousands of other people
watching us but hey what's up Casey
how's things how are things going
yeah that's cool leave a comment in this
description below
let's give this mysterious slip of paper
it is at midnight come back to the desk
to claim your box
[Music]
super I've got one for you and one for a
giveaway for whoever you want okay
I came to
two boxes like plural Xbox
carry one for safety
[Music]
really how many of this homeless is so
inconvenient literally can't bring this
home scorpion this is an Xbox scorpion
yeah so you think Carmichael deserves a
second Xbox leave a comment below a
second or if you wanna give away or if
you want it also we've become way ever
to compete against me yeah it's you see
the Carmichael gets it or maybe somebody
else but how are we gonna get these home
[Music]